ご視聴ありがとうございました
神王豊臣の恋人、驚異的なツキの持ち主、千葉県出身
あのー、宅配便ですー!
宅配便です。
あ、どうも、えっと、半顧、半顧…
いえ、結構です!
それより、あの、荷物の方、よろしくお願いします。
ご苦労さんです。
はぁっ!な、なんだ!?
あ、赤ん坊?
低減だよ!低減だよ!低減だよ!低減だよ!
いや、かましいな。何の騒ぎですの?
うん、赤ん坊やないか。
ベロベロバー。めちゃめちゃ可愛いね師匠。
ねえ、師匠。この子、どこの子?
お前のだろ。
わいの?
こんな手紙が入ってた。俺は知らんぞ。
なおな。わいはまだ童貞ですよ。
したことないのに、子供できるわけないですよ。
奥さん。ほな、わで学校行ってきますわ。
こら。なんでこんな日だけ学校行くんだ。
実は、わい誠実真面目な学生でして。
それより、その赤ん坊。
とっとと警察届けた方がええと思いますよ。
ほな、さいなら。
いっ!
タグー!なんて、ひじょうなやつだ!
パープ、パープ…
かわいそうに、なんかおもちゃがいるな。
これしかないな。
クーラー、きてぐらーん。つみきだじょー。
ちんいつ…
お前、麻雀わかんのか!?
パープ、パープ…
ま、まさかな。
な、じゃあ、あの、町はどれかわかるかな?わかんねえだろうなぁ。
てって!
何?
偶然だよなぁ。
よし。
これの休めはどーれだ?
てって!
天才だ!
というわけなんですわ、ええ。
うん、あの豊臣に隠し語がねぇ。
アキナちゃん、あんな男は早く忘れて、 オラと幸せになるべ幸せに。
バカバカしい。
あの豊臣くんに隠し語作るほどの 会社はあると思う?
まあねぇ。
あ、それ論だよ。
あ。
リーチ一発、メンチン。
なんだかんだ言って、 しっかり動揺しとりますな、アキナハン。
おっと、噂をすればだぜ。
トヨタミくん、その子いったいあなたのなんなのよ
よくぞ聞いてくれた
この子は神様がくださった俺のワンダーベイビーなのさ
やっぱりあなたの子供なのね
違うよ
この子はマージャンの申し子天才ベイビーポンターなんだ
天才ベイビーポンター?
まあ見てなって
はっ、豊臣の野郎、じゃんそうに赤ん坊なんぞ担ぎ出し合って、ふざけるなよ!
よーし、三巡目、ダマテン。決まったぜ。
うん、いい匹でちゅね。
ダマダマ!
へぇ、あのおじさんダマ張ってんの。
バ、バカ言ってんじゃねえよ!
ダママ!
へぇ、そらまち。
おめえ、そんなガキに頼らなきゃいけねえほど落ちぶれたのか?
なこと言って、小田君、ズボシじゃないの?
声がチルベンビブラートしてるよ。無理!
でいち!
野郎、ドラなんか切りやがって。
なめんな!
こぼこぼ!
メッタスピン一発三尺ドラドラインペッコ!
さらに裏、ドラドラ!
親のサンバイバー!
どうだ、ポンタの実力を思い知ったか?
ガキだと思って油断したべ、シン太郎。
な、なんだぞ!
勝負の世界に情けは無用だ。
相手が女子供と言えど手加減しねえど。
おぉ、出た出た!三色ドラ1位5200だよ!
うるせぇ!泣いたってダメだよ!
おら、展望よこせ!展望!
痛い!痛い!痛い!痛い!痛い!
何すんだ!このガキャット!
おかしい!ポンタがこんなにむずかるなんてどうしてだ!
あんた、お尻が汚れてるぜ。
嘘だー!
はいはい、今綺麗にしてあげまちゅからねー
いい加減にしろよな
はーい、落ちまいでちゅよー
ふーらー、お尻が綺麗になったらツボもいいねー
はい、リーチ!
リーチ!
手加減しねーと言っただよ、リーチなら泣いてやるだ
チーだ!
あら、クッティメアの!
こ、こ、こら出せ!吐き出せってばよ!
こ、よーく噛み噛みするんだぞ!
わあ、来たで!もういらねえこんなもの!
泣かないんだろ!一発ツボ!
さすがだわ、豊臣くん。
赤ちゃんの特徴を生かしきって、勝負に役立てるなんて。
やっぱり二人は本当の親子。
もう、違うってば、アキナちゃん。
言い訳は無用ですせ、師匠。
そのコンビネーションは、本物の親子や。
しかし、その親子の絆は、ワイが断ち切ったな!
城は場に一枚のみ。
諸田。
いーち!
なんやねん!こっちのほう勝て、天敗やぞ!
レイジ!
下田!一品、頭を取っ替えられた。
ロー!ティーチニコニコ本一ハネバーン!
か、勝った!こいつら相手に本物だ!ポルタは麻雀の天才だ!
よっし!こうなったら僕がお前を世界一の麻雀師に仕立て上げてみせるからな!
大輔
誰ですかあなた
私大輔の母親です
大輔を返してください
ポンタ君のお母さん
だからその呼び方はやめなさいよ
大輔です返してください
この子は天才ベイビーポンタだ大輔なんかじゃない
ごめんなさいもう絶対宅配便で捨て子なんてしませんから
だいすけを返して!
おとりもいやがな!
だめだ!だめだ!ポンタは僕が育てるんだ!
豊臣くん…
ポンタでもチータでもいいから、早く消してやれって!
いやだ!いやだい!
はい、分かった。豊臣秀之並びにポンタの母。
その赤ん坊を賭けて勝負し、勝った方を本当の母親と認め、
あっぱれこれにて一件落着、リーチ一発、日の用心!
ではどうだ?
私、やります!
負けるもんか!
チュン!
出たー!名本賞三連!
そう、大助、あくまでママから当たるのね。
大助を捨てたママが憎いのね。
へへへ。ポンタはね、マージャンの天才なんですよ。ポンタはね、僕のために上がってくれるんですよ。
はぁ、そう。三層ポン。
あっ!奥さん!上がってもないのに、開けちゃダメだ!
大助!換算ピンを振り込んで!ママと一緒にお家へ帰りましょう!
ふん、ポンタはわざと振り込んだりゃしねーよ。
パーフィー!
えぇ!?な、何をするんだ、ポンタ!
パーフィー、メア!
や、やめろぉ!
ロン、太陽ドラッソ!
ママ!
アホ!大助、帰ってきてくれたのね!
ママ、もう絶対離したりしませんからね
ママ
ポン太
美女、ここはわいらがポン太の代わりになりますやん
これにて一件落着、リーチ一発安全運転
ポン太
こうして赤ん坊は無事母親のもとへ帰っていった
一人都会に取り残された豊臣の胸に拒来するのは
果たして嫉妬か憧れか
甘酸っぱい思いを胸に豊臣は
たまにはふるさとの母へ
手紙でもしたためようかと思うのでありました
ママ
テンボーブレイズ
レッジ
クラッシュ
レッドポーツ
いや、負けちゃった
リーチ一発、メンホン初、三アンク大人さんだぜベイビー
あなたって強いよね
そう、俺は強い、絶対に強い
この強さそこら辺にうずめておくにはあまりにも惜しい
そうだろ、マイベイビー
私強い人って大好き
ご褒美あげる
分かったよベイビー
こうなったら残された道はただ一つ
プロの麻雀師になってみんなをアウと言わせてやるぜ
期待の超新星現れるってな
待て
あの野郎
どこ探してもいねえと思ったら
あんな隠れ家に裏書いたつもりだろうがそうはとにゃがおろさねー
ん
やっぱりかん
ああああああ
me
おとなしく、オラたちと一緒に来るだよ。
助けてくれ!
なんだ、この口笛は。
あ、あそこだ!
何者だ、お前。
な、名を名乗れ!
俺はあまねくすべてのジャンピューターを撃破してきた隠れ天才麻雀師だ
お兄さんたち俺と勝負するだけの度胸があるかい
じゃあ行くぞよ
おい行くめいこ
こらこらこらちょっと待てベイビー
なんだよ
俺もメンツに入れてくれって言ってんだよ
お呼びじゃねえよ勝手にジャンソーでもどこでも行けばいいだろうが
ちょっと待てしんたろ
こいつ結構いいかもかもしれねえぞ
ん?そうかもな
だろ?
そうすると、誰かが抜けなきゃなんねえな
だな
言い出しっぺえ
そうやって最初っから素直にメンツに加えてくれればいいんだよ、ベイビー
やんだよ、バラ!
リーチ!
いきなりハネマンで先行だぜ
なんだかな
あり
ローソン
ロンリーチ一発
メンホントン発
こんなリーチにローソン切るかよ
ジャンピューターこそ甘やかすだけだろうが
しゃねえべ
俺もメンホン貼ってただもんよ
この手の奴は調子づかせるとろくなことねえぞ
リーチ
ラン
リーチ一発メホイペコ
なんで出るんだ三層が
調子づかせてんのはおめえだんべ
バカコケ俺だってテンパってんだ
しゃねえよ
よーし、迷彩バッチリ
リーチ
おめーは降りるってことを知らんのか
当たられたってどうせ同じ点数じゃん
そんか
こいつは所詮ジャンピューター専門なんだ
最近の麻雀ゲームは進化したとはいえ
まだまだ二人打ちが主流だ
だから振っても積もられても点数が同じ場合が多い
自然こういうブリブリの打ち方になっちまうんだな
これなら普通9番を切って3色と1通の両天秤に受けるね
当然9ピン切り防天速リーだぜ
やっぱり
どうだ
ローリーチ一発のみ
スカーン!
出すほんも出すほん。
こういう、ぼうてんジャンシーが乗ると怖ぇぞ。
リーチ!
スカーンから合わせ撃ちしよう。
同じく、イーピン!
ローインポーズ!
なわけねぇだろ!
こら!シンタロウが先に来てるだろ!
だろう ええじゃねえだよ振りてんだよ
と遠い面しか見ていなかった ジャンピューター野郎が陥りやすい
罠だな よーし気を取り直して
うりっちー 遠い面からはちーはできねえの
パッタ!
あっ、イテッ
センテンパップ!
えぇ?
人間相手の麻雀は厳しいベッド!
チ!
分かってるパイ!泣かすなよ!
ヤスはテンデバを見てねぇからな
何をごちゃごちゃと、オラだってテンパってんだど?
もう頭つたんだ!
クイッジ!
よーし、果たせベイビー。
行け!
ロンダ!リーチ一発、メンホン一平台!
シャケベイビー!
でで、人間は次エビ。いや、ファミリーマージャンのケイコとショウはもっと強かった。
ほう、それじゃあ、リーチ!
この群れ、強えのか!
そんなもんじゃないぜ、ベイビー
ほら、そんなら
リーチ
リーチ一発、タイヤをチートへ
まだまだだぜ、ベイビー
リーチ
もしかしてこう来て、リーチ
リーチ一発だけだ
もうそんなバキュースを着てアンパイ落とせばいいじゃないか
上がれば勝ちだよ
それじゃこの若そうと何ら変わらん
うちの通わない暴転そくりジャンピューターマーシャンじゃないか
お前の言いたいことはよくわかった
だがしかし
この方が早いじゃん やっぱ
リーチ
このわからずやがお前たちに教えてやる
人間の人間による人間のための打法
ロンだ
ロン
こんにちは
あきらちゃん、入った入った。君にぴったりの打ち手なんだよ。
いや、1300点しかないじゃない。
見てろよ、ジャンピューターこそ。究極の人間ジャンピューターを見せてやる。
チーだ。ポンだ。ポンだ。チーだ。裸探機だ。
バカタンキだい!
よぉ!シロのみ!
ほら逃げて!ほら逃げたら逃げ!
これはゲセンの脱がし麻雀じゃないっての!
あんたたち今喜んでたでしょ!
ジャンピューターで鍛えたこの腕で、この女絶対ひっぺがしてやるぜ。
ポン!
ぽん!
まさかな
しかしこっちも告知がかかってるんだ
ここは一発勝負
どうせい!
じゃじゃーん!
大数字ツーイーソー
シェキラベイビーツー!
じゃじゃーん!
恐るべきジャンピュータ小僧は
さらに上を行く人間ジャンピューターアキラの前に敗れ去った
しかし戦いは終わっていない
第2第3のジャンピューター小僧が現れないという確証はないのだ
人々が麻雀の心を取り戻すその日まで
頑張れアキラ
戦えスーパーズガントヨットミ
この次のお話は
私の口から言うのはちょっとつらいの
豊臣くんのことを思ってやったんだけど
ちょっとやりすぎたみたい
ごめんね豊臣くん
次回スーパーズガン
泣かせるツモジャン
パート1パート2
きっと見てね
眠っちゃ
やっ
インターネットバースバース 南ハローロール
せずなさわぐなあわてるな
パイをつかんねばせんぞくのまんのゆめがわく
うんふうてんふうとりしょうかくる
とべてくるんだといめんさん
つかんとうかねばならぬのだ
リジークはスピードリーチ
しばちゃかんちゃばやんなかま
勝負かけたら情け無用の狙い撃ち
君はアゲマの主席じゃないか
ロードマンガンズフォローよ
スカントン 幸せスカボード
スパスカ
やりでやりのまんまく心
飛んでいけば何か
スタート
ここは三面待ちどころ
ユクダカンキャン オクシムソモノセギガハダ
スーモーミーモーマー ケンクーニーやリュウイテン
勝手飲み干すビールが美味い
スカンゾー オザカワイドチガケ
スカンゾー スカンゾー ガキカメッタ
アヌーロイロー!